[Music]  hello friend welcome to it i knew it i  knew it i knew it  oh i knew it  heaven boom here i am cause i did it and  i knew it  clouds check  gates  check  saint peter check  me  check  oh i knew it i wanted to do bad but i  knew  it would be  not good i didn't do heroin i didn't do  cocaine i didn't even have a glass of  white zinfandel when my wife and  daughter said that that would make me  loosen up and relax and i said you know  what make me loosen up and relax going  to heaven  i knew it what do you do with gum you  chew it i knew it what's the politically  correct term for an eskimo inuit  i was only on earth for 32 years but i  will be judged on that finite time and  rewarded in heaven  forever  [Music]  forever  that felt fantastic  this really is heaven  [Music]  you